hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
speech and communication how we converse
with each other is an important aspect
of temperance for Cicero in on duties
and he actually gives us quite a few
discussions and even guidelines about
how we should talk with each other now
why is that the case why would that be
so important and why would it fall under
temperance as opposed to the other
virtues it's not to say that we can't
also observe say justice or wisdom or
courage in how we talk but temperance
has to do with how we regulate our
behavior how we live out the life of a
rational creature and for the ancient
Greeks and the Romans reason and speech
were very closely connected with each
other to be the rational animal doesn't
just mean to be cerebral up in our heads
it means to be the community
communicative animal the animal that
talks to each other and so we can do
this well or we can do this poorly the
first thing that he talks about in
chapter 29 has to do with humor and he
tells us that you know first of all
humor that's for when we've taken care
of the serious earnest business but it
is an important aspect of life and when
we're being humorous or playful with
each other when we're Justins Latian
goes then we need to remain within
certain limits we want to be and what we
nowadays call good taste and so he
contrasts two kinds of wit or humor the
one is coarse boorish buffoonish obscene
indecent is how it's translated but
absque annum is is actually how it's
being discussed there and the other is
refined witty the sort of thing that
brings us together and it's interesting
if we look at his examples he talks
about attic old comedy and that means
Aristophanes now if you've ever read
Aristophanes an english translation you
might actually think yes Cicero is right
about that that's very refined
stuff if you read it in a you know
translation that sticks fairly close to
the original Greek and especially if you
read it with somebody who catches the
plays on words or if you even read
Plato's symposium he talks about
Socratic dialogues right if you read
Plato's symposium and you you see all of
the sexual jokes in it then you might
not actually share Cicero's view that
this provides us with a mob of how to be
refined in talking about comedy
especially when we go to the the next
key point but be that as it may we can
think in our own time about where do the
lines run what counts as humor that's in
good taste and where do we say that's
really cross the line now you're just
being obscene now you're just being
gross now you're just being vulgar now
you're you're saying stuff that you you
shouldn't say now you're going beyond
the limits now the second thing that
Cicero talks about is bodily functions
and this is in chapter 35 and he says
some very interesting things again we
may not find ourselves in complete
agreement but the goal here is to
understand what temperance in speech and
communication looks like through Cicero
so he tells us that you know the things
that concern the lower bodily organs
defecation you know getting rid of waste
sexual functions those sorts of things
really we shouldn't be talking about
those you're not being temperate in
bringing those into conversation he even
goes so far as to say listen there's
there's really nothing wrong with those
functions although you should keep them
hidden away do them you know out of
other people's sight but it's obscene to
talk about them and he faults the
ancient cynics and he says even some
Stoics who are more cynics than Stoics
for making the following argument it's
okay to talk about murder or you know
stealing why is it wrong to talk about
going to the bathroom or having sex or
any of those
sorts of things and Cicero says it's
it's wrong to talk about them it gives a
fence you know it's indecent that he
gives an argument of his own which is
really quite interesting here again you
may not actually buy into it but it's
good to take a look at he says human
modesty has followed this careful
contrivance of nature all right minded
people keep out of sight what nature is
hidden and take pains to respond to
nature's demands as privately as
possible in the case of those parts of
the body which only serve nature's needs
neither the parts nor the functions are
called for by are called by their real
names to perform these functions is
nothing immoral but to speak of them is
indecent and his argument is listen you
know these are kind of hidden away right
the face you look at the face but you
don't look at the private parts that's
hidden now you might say was Cicero what
are you talking about how are they
hidden away that are out in plain sight
if you're naked and since was a wolf
don't be naked then right you you've got
clothes to wear and again we may want to
see this as sort of a reflection of the
cultural mores of his own time I don't
even think this was necessarily shared
by all Romans so this is one we can
probably set aside but look at it as an
interesting curiosity are there things
that we should not actually talk about
do we have similar matters in our own
time that although there's nothing wrong
with doing the action we're not supposed
to talk about it that's an interesting
thing to think about
chapters 36 37 and 38 he gives us what
he calls rules for conversations
ceremony and he says listen people have
given us rules for oratory for for
talking with other people about public
business trying to get things done but
nobody has really given us rules for how
to talk with each other say at dinner
parties which were a very important
thing back then or you know with
acquaintances on the street how should
we talk with them and here he lays out a
couple interesting criteria the first
thing that he talks about is style or
diction you could call it right he says
that it should be clear klaris right and
musical swabiz and he says this is
something you can actually work on you
can you can improve your articulation
you know we've got that old joking
phrase when somebody's mumbling we say
hey buddy take the marbles out and if
you don't know where that comes from
people when they were practicing
elocution would actually take marbles
and put them in their mouths this goes
all the way back to demosthenes in
Athens and they would try to talk with
these marbles in their mouths so that
they would have to practice getting
better and better and better at speaking
and it projecting and so then when you
take the marbles out you're gonna sound
a lot better right so when we say to
somebody take the marbles out we're
saying hey mumble mouth I can't figure
out what the hell you're saying so you
know if we're going to be be temperate
we should actually learn how to speak
well we should articulate our terms we
shouldn't belong to a mumble of them
right so we might actually extend that
to accents I know some people
everyone's no one else's I can't
understand dr. Sadler's accent well I
speak Midwestern standard with you know
kind of a Wisconsin twang different
people speak in other ways right
so Cicero would probably have some some
guidelines about how we ought to be
speaking English what kind of English we
ought to speak I don't know that it
would be British English like in all the
old Roman movies you know there's no
reason to think that that Romans would
speak like Brits this gets much more
interesting when we get the content
though he says that when we're talking
with other people we should be easy that
means that we should not be too quick to
give or take offence we should be not
dogmatic meaning that we shouldn't try
to push our own points onto other people
as if they automatically agree with us
and we should be witty when it's
appropriate to be wit
so maybe not at a funeral right you
don't go up in the receiving line and
then tell a singer about the person who
just died that's inappropriate right
maybe you save that for later on during
the reception when people have had a few
drinks and they're you know starting to
share stories right
but even then maybe you respect other
people's feelings and you don't talk
about it
so exercising good judgment and not
pushing your own views onto other people
this doesn't mean that you can't express
your opinions or that you can't argue
for your views but you should take
others into consideration when you're
doing so he also says that you don't
want to be selfish in conversation let
other people have a turn let everyone
talk you don't have to dominate the
conversation that's not a sign of being
a good person that's a sign of being
insecure or boorish or inattentive to
others another thing that he says that's
really interesting is that we we should
be as he says free of exhibitions of
passion that is mental excitement that's
excessive and uncontrolled by reason let
our conversation be free from such
emotions or passions what does he have
in mind there does he mean that you
should talk like I'm in a monotone and
you should never show any emotion be
like a robot no he's not saying that you
can be excited about things as a matter
of fact there's a little bit of an
aggression you know I I will sometimes
say I'm excited about this thing that's
coming out you know in stoicism today or
what's going on with stoic on people
like the Stoics they can't be excited
about things that's on stoic no actually
it isn't the Stoics thought there were
good emotions and there were a whole set
of them but they were controlled by
reason they were temperate it's the
intemperate emotions that we have to
watch out for certain of them are always
going to be intemperate the Stoics
thought for example anger is a
fundamental problem cicero actually
discusses this here is it ever
appropriate to speak angrily at another
person generally no what would be the
exception
when we need to do so for the sake of
correcting them or for public order we
might also add in there when your kid is
going to put his or her you know hand
right on the hot stove and you're like
don't do that and you shout out right
and maybe you do so angrily he says
there might be need of administering
reproof we can use a more emphatic tone
of voice that even assume an appearance
of being angry but we don't want to
actually be angry when we do this the
harshness has to serve some sort of
purpose in that same section in chapter
38 he also talks about the need to be
courteous and considerate with those who
were talking with including those who
are political opponents or in our own
time the people who we disagree with
about fundamental manners all of these
are ways in which our our speech our
conversation our communication with
others can fall under this virtue of
temperance that is so central to the
Stoics
you